vamos al repaso de la información
económica con Daniela Blandón Daniela
Saludos Nuevamente para usted Hola
Ángela Buenos días es importante para
los televidentes que se unen a nuestro
programa en este momento hablar de este
acuerdo preliminar que finalmente se
logró entre Joe biden y Kevin mccarthy
para Elevar el techo de la deuda en
Estados Unidos Pues sí Ángela después de
intensas negociaciones también de un
frenético fin de semana el presidente
Joe biden y su contraparte el líder
republicano Kevin mccarthy por fin
lograron consensos que parecían
imposibles todo con el único objetivo de
darle permiso a la nación para
endeudarse más de lo que tiene aprobado
hasta el momento y también hasta después
de las próximas elecciones es decir por
dos años el acuerdo negociado a Puerta
cerrada ya tiene luz verde y no se
conoce en su integridad Pero sí hay
detalles
las características clave aquí son en
primer lugar que se aumenta el límite de
la deuda el gobierno no incumplirá la
próxima semana suponiendo que se apruebe
el proyecto que significa eso significa
que durante dos años ni los demócratas
ni los republicanos tienen que
preocuparse por golpear el techo de la
deuda del gobierno es decir Cuánta deuda
puede emitir en segundo lugar parece que
en el mejor de los casos aumenta
ligeramente el gasto de defensa con
respecto al del año en curso así como el
apoyo a la salud de los veteranos pero
luego probablemente parece congelar la
mayoría de los otros gastos internos
como medio ambiente transporte atención
médica entre otros
Angela vale la pena recordar que el
punto central del desacuerdo era que los
demócratas querían más impuestos y los
republicanos menos gastos todo para
reducir el déficit y se sabe que ambos
han cedido un poco pero hay un caso muy
particular y es el de la llamada
generación x es decir los
aproximadamente 65 millones de
habitantes que nacieron entre 19 65 y
1980 muchos de ellos son beneficiarios
del llamado programa de nutrición
suplementaria pues este acuerdo aumentan
las condiciones de acceso a ese programa
hoy en día Cuando cumplen 50 años ya no
tienen que tener requisitos de trabajo
según lo acordado ahora entre los 50 y
los 54 años van a tener que trabajar al
menos 20 horas a la semana si quieren
recibir esta ayuda con excepción de los
que tengan dependientes a cargo este fue
un punto para los republicanos porque
ellos dicen que esta clase de requisitos
alienta a la gente a volver al trabajo y
también pues hace parte es solamente un
ejemplo de todo lo que tiene este
acuerdo pues mire sabiendo que iba a
haber renuncias uno podría pensar que ya
El Ejecutivo puede respirar un poco más
después de este principio de acuerdo sin
embargo Todavía queda un camino que
recorrer qué es lo que viene y es un
camino bastante espinoso porque ahora
tienen que guiar este proyecto a través
de las fracturas partidistas del
Congreso con miembros de las salas más
radicales a frenar ciertos puntos para
el martes fue convocado una reunión de
la comisión de reglas de la cámara para
discutir este proyecto de ley y es
justamente allí en la cámara baja en
donde los republicanos controlan una
estrecha mayoría de 222 contra 213 y se
necesita una mayoría simple es decir al
menos 218 para votar la aprobación final
una vez pasa en la cámara le sigue el
senado lo veíamos ahí en las imágenes
allí los demócratas tienen una mayoría
de 51 a 49 la discusión podría tomarse
entonces todo el resto de esta semana y
si hubiera un empate de un 50-50 en el
senado la vicepresidenta kamala Harris
entraría a desempatar ya una vez si se
consigue toda esta aprobación en el
mejor de los escenarios el acuerdo iría
a la casa blanca para que bailen lo
firme como ley todo esto lo difícil es
que tiene que ocurrir antes del 5 de
junio que es cuando el país podría
quedarse sin fondos para pagar sus
facturas Eso es en una semana bueno Y
usted sabe que el panorama político se
interpreta mucho también en lo económico
Así que le quiero preguntar Cómo
responden los mercados Pues los índices
bursátiles europeos cayeron levemente el
lunes no hay gran impulso debido a que
no operan no hay ni Wall Street por ser
festivo ni tampoco Reino Unido no era el
día para que Wall Street no operara pero
la noticia de que se alcanzó un acuerdo
sobre el techo de deudas y mantuvo
positivos otros mercados vamos por
ejemplo a ver en Asia como el níquel de
Japón marcó máximos de 33 años Aunque
Hong Kong sí experimentó caídas después
de que fuera revelada una caída en las
ganancias de las empresas industriales
de China y quiero ser una acotación para
hablar de Turquía en el primer día hábil
después de la segunda vuelta la moneda
turca alcanzó un nuevo mínimo histórico
de 20 libras liras por dólar ha caído
más del 7% desde principios de año y más
del 90% durante la década en tanto en
cuanto a las acciones su principal
índice de referencia cotizaba hasta en
un cuatro coma cinco por ciento más este
lunes Daniel el agradecimiento para
usted mañana nos vemos acá con más
economía Pero por supuesto que sí